أعتقد أن رحلتي الأولى كانت في
حوالي 12 عامًا ، لقد كان الكثير من
الحرية
والسعادة الخالصة الأدرينالين التي تحولت
إلى فضول وشغف
كما ترون الباقي هو أن التاريخ
استغرق حوالي عامين لإكمال
رخصة طيار النقل الجوي الخاص بي
في 17 عامًا.  الأصغر في
الفصل كان التحدي الأكبر بالنسبة لي ،
ولكن كان علينا القيام بالكثير من
الدراسة بمفردنا قبل أن نتمكن من الوصول إلى
الجزء الممتع المتمثل في الكثير من الطيران
بمجرد التخرج ، إنها ليست نهاية الأمر
وكل طائرة  يتطلب
تدريبًا محددًا ولن تتوقف أبدًا عن
تعلم
[الموسيقى]
لطالما كانت فرصة أن تصبح طيارًا
فرصة عظيمة بالنسبة لي
، كما أن يومًا عاديًا بالنسبة
لنا سيبدأ بالموجز اليومي مع
الطيارين وأفراد الطاقم خارج
أوقات العمل التي قاموا خلالها  أطلعنا
على الحالة في اليوم السابق وإذا كانت هناك أي
مهمة جارية نحتاج إلى معرفتها
بمجرد الانتهاء من التمهيد ، نذهب
كطاقم ومسعف للتحقق من
الطائرة والمعدات ،
إنه أمر هائل  لدينا فرصة بالنسبة لي
لأكون أول طيارة لتكون قادرة على أن
تكون قدوة بالنسبة للفتيات والنساء الصغيرات
، وأنا لا أستخف بذلك ، إنه
يسعدني أن أعرف
أنني كنت الأولى ولكني لن
أكون  الاخير